this is Wednesday November 2nd six days
until the 2016 presidential election and
this is the closer as a student of
history and as an individual of largely
German heritage I have wondered since my
teens what it would have been like what
it must have been like for distant
relatives I will never know to have been
a German and to watch what seemed like a
strange but evidently unimportant
political movement rise up from the
fringes of my own society and from the
unsound mind and evil soul of one
individual what would it be like to
watch a man laughed at more than feared
spewing bizarre but hardly
earth-shattering invective year after
year in the shadowy corners and then to
see him in real time and in my native
language double down on his rhetoric and
hate and convoluted revenge fantasies
and then triple down on them and
quadruple and quintuple what would have
been like to watch in amazement from
your home from the only society you and
your family had ever known to see the
country you thought you knew react not
with trebled laughter and quadrupled
outrage but with growing acceptance and
enthusiasm what would it be like to see
and hear in your own language and own
time the hate in which the man
trafficked and the power he sought to
usurp become part of your daily life
what would it be like to hear a
demagogue a monster in the making
campaigning for office and promising to
disband opposition parties and jail the
opposing candidate what would we like to
hear those who follow him see their most
secret violent fantasies coming to life
burnished with the authenticity and the
authority of a man who had moved the bar
between right and wrong towards himself
who could with a few words validate
their desires to hate and exclude and
kill what would it be like to see it
unfold in preliminary elections and in
ever increasingly fevered rallies as
millions handed over their votes never
dreaming that they would be repaid only
with fear and privation and death and
the destruction of their own country
what would it be like to watch as the
sober agencies of government gradually
became corrupted first to influence the
outcomes of Elections than to separate a
minority from the day-to-day life of
my country then to remove them to camps
and uncertain fates there what would it
be like to watch as the police became
first militarized and then politically
aggressive and partisan to figuratively
then literally adopt the logos and the
clothing of the rising mob what would it
be like to watch the figure at the
center of this ever darkening storm
begin to promise Accords on my behalf on
my country's behalf with the dictators
around the world what would it be like
and when would it have hit home that
what I was watching was no longer
politics nor the governance of a country
but the normalization of repression and
horror all this I have wondered for
decades what would it be like to see my
country devolve and deteriorate from
democracy to mindless soulless cult
worship thanks to Donald Trump I am
getting the chance to find out last
Saturday a rally goer in Phoenix spits
at the media pen and starts shouting USA
USA he's captured on video as he does so
day before yesterday he self identifies
as george mandela phoenix and he claims
it was not an anti-semitic chant but
empathy for a group of hispanics at the
trump rally who pronounced us a that way
because that was to what you do at Trump
rallies empathize with Hispanics when
dehl does not explain why his empathy
was followed by telling reporters and
photographers that they were quote going
down and adding quote the Jews run the
country anyway in Cleveland on October
22nd a man shouts lugan press at
reporters that's an alt right term today
it translates as liar press it was used
to describe anything Western in the East
Germany of the 1960s it even dates back
to the propaganda of the Kaiser in the
First World War but it gained an added
meaning liar press or lying Jewish press
or just lying Jews in the Germany of the
1930s last Sunday another man at another
Trump rally yells at the press pit quote
put the camera on us [ __ ]
put the camera on us queer he self
identifies as Matt Fox of Palm Springs
and he explains he's proud to have said
that in beside
which quote queer isn't a bad word queer
means happy yesterday a member of
Trump's agricultural Advisory Committee
tweeted a poll result that read quote
Trump 44 [ __ ] 43 last Sunday has that
rally began in Las Vegas and opening
speaker named route fantasizes about the
death of Hillary Clinton and then says
quote we're putting the DC elite on
notice we're coming to tear it down
we're coming to kick your ass and we're
coming to put you in prison since a year
ago June and in the campaign that has
followed Trump crisscross the country in
an airplane descending from the clouds
into the arms of growing numbers of
fanatics at ever-larger rallies he gave
them a positive message promising
something for everyone and then ascended
back into the clouds we could go tonight
he descended at Kinston North Carolina
his plane taxiing towards the crowd of
fanatics a huge spotlight was directed
on the door right next to the giant
letters spelling Trump and he walked
down the airport stairs and began to
speak and soon an older man in a dress
shirt and a jacket and sunglasses moved
slowly towards the stage and got to
within about 20 feet of Trump he waved a
piece of paper in the air and shouted
Donald Donald Trump spotted him pointed
him out to security and as the man was
removed Trump said quote we have a
protester by the way were you paid
$1,500 to be a thug you can get him out
get him out out Trump went on to riff
about what a disgrace it was and how
tough his people are the man turns out
to be an ex-marine and he's 63 years old
he's named CJ Kerry and he's a trump
voter and he's corresponding with Trump
since 1992 and he's reportedly had more
than 40 different Trump signs in his
North Carolina yard and they keep
getting vandalized and he keeps getting
new ones and the piece of paper in this
ex-marines hand was a note urging Trump
to not lose the election by continuing
to be impolite and unwelcoming to
minorities but to Trump he wasn't one of
his people as mr. Kerry approached him
Trump did not see the veteran nor a
penpal nor a man with
39 or 40 Trump yard signs nor a
supporter all Trump saw was that mr.
Kerry is african-american
so Trump called him a thug called him a
thug the same way George Lyndell called
the reporters Jews from Jew a say the
same way Matt Fox called them [ __ ]
and queers the same way the Trump mob in
Cleveland called them lugan press the
same way Wayne root called
all of Trump's opponents DC elite to be
put in prison what would it like to see
my country devolve and deteriorate from
democracy to mindless soulless cult
worship thanks to Donald Trump I am
getting the chance to find out a close
of the paragraph from a website called
history place calm I played a little
trick here I already quoted this
paragraph about a minute ago I have
changed just two words in it both of
them proper nouns in the campaign that
followed he criss-crossed the country in
an airplane descending from the clouds
into the arms of growing numbers of
fanatics at ever-larger rallies he gave
them a positive message promising
something for everyone then ascended
back into the clouds
history place.com then adds that the
candidate who descended from the clouds
in his own airplane made his fanatics
more and more ludicrous promises such as
quote in the Third Reich every German
girl will find a husband that's the
closer I'm Keith Olbermann watch this
space